hey guys I'm riding right so we're gonna
check out from raka raka
oh god I'm actually kind of nervous for
this one because I they go all out yeah
real-life Mortal Kombat fatalities I'm
actually genuinely nervous diseases okay
all right you ready Cassandra let's do
it
you got quite a new Mortal Kombat hazard
[__] how is it not [__] it's the [__]
fatalities of [__]
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
every time you think that shit's over
okay yeah this the saw part was like oh
god the grill was bad enough yeah and
then oh dude them ripping out the mouth
do not like that [__] at all I eat
anything mouths up laughter of fear now
things that was awful I probably should
have told you I'm actually like I handle
blood you can't handle blood I showed
her Mortal Kombat X fatalities real like
from the game beforehand so she gained
blood I know and I said this was gonna
be real life oh [__]
they went oh man I'm fine I'm fine I'm
not gonna faint
they went all out man real life the
mother got the worst one because the eye
thing people really do that boys ripping
out the mouth oh I that got me yeah yeah
oh that saw though and that poor kid he
just wanted to go to school he had it
coming
anyone who goes to school ends at Brook
these days you die out of college anyway
guys thanks for tuning in if you're new
to the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects you can check out Cassandra
Michael's channel a lot of cool original
songs on there with thousands upon
thousands of years meaning she knows
what the [__] she's doing and you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram Twitter
me on vine and periscope let's do it
Keshawn August McLaury McClure hey Ryan
my name is Keshawn aka Frozone aka dark
chocolate I don't like a little bit of
dark chocolate of me know what I mean
and I really want a shout out I love
your channel and I also you don't think
I've seen a single real rejects video
that I haven't laughed at although I
laugh at pretty much anything remotely
funny Wow way to give a comment and just
take it back anyways thanks for the
entertainment I hope you gained all the
product placement the world has to offer
trust me I'm really working on it P yes
a couple of friends and I just started a
channel called not gaming and one day we
shall product place everything everyone
check out the not gaming channel it is
about nothing it is a nothing okay shot
he's black he's black alright brother
yeah that's why he got doc Shockley cuz
his dick is dog and no no dude Keshawn
man I love you to mcclure me you know
McClure's that's when you put your penis
in the person's butt and then they
should and then you start [__] the
[__] kind of like who makes these things
me for most of them I couldn't I can't
keep going good that makes them I had a
lot more to do but a half do Patrick do
you girl Cassandra